[Music]
you were talking about pranks and I want
to make sure I get this during the
primaries your dad very interested in
getting the endorsement of Governor
Schwarzenegger and you actually had a
device it's a box it gives you Arnold
Schwarzenegger voice and you used it
Matt to play a prank on thank you I
looked at you John look at the name tag
yeah no the other guy you know the other
guy you use it to play a prank on your
dad that actually seems pretty mean and
we have have the footage here let's take
a look
governor Mitt Romney how are you are you
I'm just fine governor how are you doing
today good good
what can I do for you we'll ask you a
bunch of questions now won't ahead of
them answered immediately go right ahead
and shoot who is your daddy and what
does he do
[Applause]
nothing cleanses the mind of a bad prank
than biting into a giant sandwich Matt
was he irritated because he was after
that for a few months I was fearing
retribution I really was but he still
hasn't gotten me so thanks for the
reminder though thanks